(upbeat music)
- I'm Priscilla and
I'm one of the chalkers
for @ChalkOfTheDay.
I first got started doing it
because it was just a way
for me to find an escape
from the typical routine at MIT.
It really let me with my partner, Jessica,
to kind of artistically experiment,
and challenge ourselves in ways
that really ended up surprising us.
- I thinks it's nice
because we're all very busy
and so, setting us
apart an hour every week
to do something artistic
and not think about work
is really nice.
- I'm Sarah, I'm a senior.
And I've been chalking
since freshman year.
So it's been like six semesters.
Awesome (laughs).
- What is it, it was like
a (imitates shooting).
- Oh, diagonal?
Yeah, we should do like, this.
- I'm Charleen, I'm a senior,
and I study computer science here at MIT.
Yeah, maybe like, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, okay.
- Yeah, so that's like a good middle size.
- Nice.
- I'm just looking at pictures of snowflakes.
Words are really powerful,
and so being able to, kind of
convey the meaning of the word
through the way that you write it,
is kind of interesting to me.
- There is a creative process
that I have to engage,
but it's a totally different way
that I approach a math
problem versus the way
that I approach a blank canvas.
Oh, okay.
- [Charleen] Slightly less the...
- It puts a smile on people's faces.
It spreads a positive message
to people who pass by.
It also, hopefully,
encourages other people
to pursue some form of art
and to be more creative
in their everyday life.
(upbeat music)